[CAT MEOWING]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Hi,
everyone. [SPEAKING TURKISH]
For the English speaking, I'll
be actually talking Turkish
so far.
But now, my presentation
will be in English
so you can go over it.
And it has all the slides, and
the code source will be public.
And I will even put this on
YouTube, once we are recorded
and this live streaming is done.
So you can get it from there.
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
Today, we'll talk
about the supercharge
your app with the YouTube API.
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[INAUDIBLE]
[CAT MEOWS]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Wouldn't it be amazing
if Google could understand
that the words that you use
when you're doing a search
weren't just words, they refer
to real things in the world,
that a building is a building,
and an animal is an animal,
and that they're not just
random strings of characters.
If we could understand that
those words are talking
about those real-world
things, then we
could do a better
job of getting you
just the content that
you want of the web.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Today, Google is
trying to build
information about
real-world connections--
is by building a
knowledge graph.
A knowledge graph is about
collecting information
about objects in the real world.
The object could be a
person, could be a book,
could be a movie, and many
other types of things.
For example, for
a famous person,
we collect relevant
data about them,
such as their date of
birth or how tall they are.
It can also connect that person
to closely related objects
in a knowledge graph.
-Let's say we're interested
in Renaissance painters,
or how about how many women
have won the Nobel Prize--
I understand the
relationships between things,
between painters
in the Renaissance
or women and the Nobel Prize.
Google can do a better
job of understanding.
Google knows exactly
what we're searching for.
-One of the first features
we're going to introduce,
which applies to the knowledge
graph, is a [INAUDIBLE]
next to the web results.
-When I had a
question to answer,
I wish we had come to
Google and that inter--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
[CHIMING]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING TURKISH]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING TURKISH]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING TURKISH]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING TURKISH]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING TURKISH]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING TURKISH]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING TURKISH]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING TURKISH]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING TURKISH]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
MALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING TURKISH]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: [LAUGHS]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]
[APPLAUSE]
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
[SPEAKING TURKISH]